thought cry primal was announced last
week and I was among the many people who
spent way too long staring at the cave
paintings preceding the reveal that gave
me quite a lot of time to think about
what I'm hoping Ubisoft are going to
deliver in the next farc rainstorm it
here's what I came up with we were all
pretty keen on unleashing elephants on
our foes in Far Cry 4
but woolly mammoths and all manner of
menacing megafauna should really up the
ante Far Cry is arguably at its best
when the sprawling open world feels
alive and populated where you can
stumble across wild beasts taking each
other wrong because that seems like the
thing to do on a Monday morning oh
what's your group of people accidentally
pissed off an elephant and deal with the
squashy consequences while some Far Cry
fans are still coming to terms with the
fact that Tamil is unlikely to feature
dinosaurs given that whole they'd have
been dead for over 65 million years
issue will hopefully see the game put
its epic megafauna saber-toothed Tigers
prehistoric bears wolves and mammoths
the good news particularly if you
eventually get to tame dead mammoths and
do the enemies for yourself Ubisoft have
hinted that encountering tribes and
enlisting their help to tackle the
wilderness will be a focus of Far Cry
primal what I'd like to see is them
handle factions in the same way fallout
does Ubisoft insinuated that certain
tribes will be your friends while others
are more interested in ripping you limb
from limb but I'd like to see the game
offer you more choice in the matter I'd
love for there to be a wide variety of
unique tribes that each have their own
lifestyle expertise culture alliances
and community it would be awesome if
primal then let you decide who to align
with as best suited to you pull out s
factions whose favor you need to juggle
and ultimately opt to either support or
destroy would be a very cool addition to
surviving the Stone Age Far Cry has
generally been punctuated by vehicles
and loud guns obviously that's probably
not going to happen
time around so it would be really good
to see you be stuff to embrace the
basics of course there will be those who
miss the wide and ridiculous arsenal of
high-powered weaponry but I figure if
you be softer going to tackle the Stone
Age setting they may as well do it right
while that trusty bow will be one to
hang on to for those of you who prefer
ranged attacks I'd love to see the
protagonist be a hardy priest or exhort
who can both give and take a beating a
hell of a lot better than his 21st
century offspring we can already assume
that melee weapon crafting is going to
be a thing but a more robust and
satisfying hand-to-hand and combat
system like the one seen in Zeno Clash
would be awesome and a weapon combat
system that gives you more options than
just light and heavy attacks would also
be great
throw in a dying light a spark or system
replaced radio towers with tall trees
and let us drift around corners on
woolly mammoths and I think we'll be
good to go well I've got you thinking
about games that encourage you to get
your hand to hand fight on another thing
I think Far Cry primal could benefit
from is taking a couple of notes from
Mad Max when it comes to survival the
Stone Age was tough really tough the
competition for food was intense though
wildlife was enormous and deadly and
humans were just beginning to find a way
to claw their way up the food chain it
would be really cool to see that
hardship reflected in the landscape as
well as the combat and overall gameplay
it would be great if primals world of
Oris took inspiration from the harsh and
unforgiving wasteland of Mad Max edible
food should be hard to identify and come
across you should never know which
plants might be poisonous and hunting
animals should be hard all that melee
combat and running around should also
really take it out of you making finding
food water and shelter in number one
priority and ideally it would also make
forming alliances with the local tribes
essential for survival let me know down
in the comment section what you want to
see from Far Cry primal and if you're
keen to see it differentiate itself from
the rest of the Far Cry series I will
catch you again next week
you